♪ ♪
>> I THINK WHAT WE NEEDED
WASHINGTON IS PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTAND --
AND BLAME A FOREST IN THE
PROCESS.
WE NEED PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHO KNOWS HOW
THE SYSTEM WORKS, WHO KNOWS HOW
TO REFORM THAT SYSTEM, AND MAKE
THAT COUNTRY BETTER.
THAT'S WHY I'M RUNNING TO BE
YOUR NEXT U.S. SENATOR FOR THE
STATE OF OHIO.
>> Tucker: JIM VANCE BECAME
FAMOUS SEVERAL YEARS AGO, A
MEMOIR, HE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
ON THIS SHOW, AND DOES HE JUST
SAW HE ANNOUNCED HOURS AGO HE'S
RUNNING FOR A U.S. SENATE SEAT
FROM THE STATE OF OHIO.
AND SEVERAL OTHER CANDIDATES TO
REPLACE SENATOR ROB PORTMAN.
THIS IS -- WHY ARE YOU DOING
THIS?
YOU'VE HAD THIS SUCCESSFUL LIFE,
AND NOW YOU ARE MOVING INTO THE
TOUGH -- VERY TOUGH BUSINESS OF
POLITICS, WHY?
>> BECAUSE I CARE ABOUT THIS
COUNTRY, AND THEY CARE ABOUT THE
STATES.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE ENTIRE
TRAJECTORY OF AMERICAN LIFE OVER
THE LAST 30 OR 40 YEARS, YOU
HAVE ELITES AND THE RULING CLASS
THAT HAVE PLUNDERED THIS
COUNTRY, MADE IT HARDER FOR
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS TO LIVE A
NORMAL LIFE.
WHEN THOSE AMERICANS DARE TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE CONDITIONS OF
THEIR OWN COUNTRY, ABOUT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER OR JOBS BEING
SHIPPED OVERSEAS, THEY GET
CALLED RACISTS AND BIGOTS,
XENOPHOBES, OR IDIOTS.
THEY NEED SOMEBODY WHO'S WILLING
TO FIGHT FOR THEM.
I JUST WANT NORMAL AMERICANS TO
KNOW THEY STILL HAVE A VOICE IN
THIS COUNTRY, THEY LOVE THIS
COUNTRY, BUT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO CRITICIZE IT WHEN IT'S NOT
WORKING FOR THEM, AND RIGHT NOW,
IT'S JUST NOT.
>> Tucker: I LOVE THAT.
THIS IS NOT FALSE FLATTERY, I
DON'T THINK I'VE MET ANYBODY WHO
UNDERSTANDS BOTH WORLDS AS WELL
AS YOU DO.
YOU GREW UP THERE IN A VERY
WORKING CLASS ENVIRONMENT, WOUND
UP AT YALE LAW SCHOOL IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WORLD, I
THINK YOU REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GONE WRONG WITH THE
COUNTRY.
YOU'RE AN INTELLECTUAL A WRITER,
ARE YOU READY FOR THE NASTINESS
OF POLITICS?
IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT WORLD.
>> I'M READY FOR THE NASTINESS
OF POLITICS, TUCKER, BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S WORTH GOING THROUGH
THAT NASTINESS TO DO SOMETHING
WORTHWHILE.
I HAVE TWO BOYS, I LOVE THOSE
KIDS COME I WANT THEM TO LIVE IN
THE SAME GREAT COUNTRY THAT I
LIVED IN.
IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING, FIGHT
BACK AGAINST WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR COUNTRY, BUT THEY'RE GOING
TO LOSE IT.
MUCH POORER, MUCH DIRTIER, MUCH
UGLIER, AND WHERE THEY CAN'T
EVEN SPEAK THEIR MIND IS
CITIZENS.
I'VE BEEN ATTACKED BY IT, EVEN
SINCE THE ANNOUNCEMENT CNN HAS
GONE UP AFTER ME, THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE GONE AFTER ME,
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF COURSE OF
THE OTHER CAMPAIGNS HAVE GONE
AFTER ME.
EVEN TIM RYAN HAS GONE AFTER ME.
IT'S TIME TO FIGHT BACK, THOUGH.
YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO STAND UP
ON THE BIG STAGE, BUT I AM.
>> Tucker: THEY KNOW YOU'RE AN
ACTUAL THREAT BECAUSE HE REALLY
DO HAVE THEIR NUMBER FOR REAL.
HOW HAVE NATIONAL REPUBLICANS --
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN, RUNNING AS
REPUBLICAN, AT TIMES YOU'VE BEEN
DISAPPOINTED BY THE NATIONAL
PARTY, HOW THEY RESPOND TO?
>> I THINK SO FAR A LOT OF THEM
ARE FRUSTRATED, AND A LITTLE
UPSET WITH ME BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
SAY WHAT'S TRUE, WHICH IS MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE DON'T CARE ABOUT
THEIR OWN VOTERS, THEY THINK
THEY'RE EITHER BIGOTED OR
STUPID.
IF THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THEIR
JOB IN THIS COUNTRY IS TO
PROTECT THEIR OWN VOTERS TO
SERVE THEIR BEST INTERESTS.
A LOT OF ESTABLISHED
REPUBLICANS, JUST LIKE A LOT OF
THE MAINSTREAM PRESS AND
CORPORATE MEDIA, DEREK AGAINST
ME, AND IT'S GOING
TO BE FINE.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO HIT YOU
PRETTY HARD.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT?
>> THEY ARE GOING TO HIT ME VERY
HARD, THEY'RE GOING TO COME
AFTER MY FAMILY AND ME
PERSONALLY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK IT'S WORTH IT.
THIS IS A COUNTRY THAT I KNOW
YOU LOVE, I LOVE, AND IT'S WORTH
IT TO WADE THROUGH THE STUFF.
I CAN TAKE A PUNCH IN THE JOB,
AS YOU KNOW.
I COME FROM ROUGH CIRCUMSTANCES,
I DID NOT COME FROM AN EASY
LIFE.
THAT PREPARED ME TO TAKE ON THE
CHALLENGE.
I'M EXCITED TO DO IT.
>> I ADMIRE YOU AND I WISH YOU
LUCK VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
>> THINK SO MUCH, TUCKER.
GO TO J.D. VANCE.COM TO SIGN UP
AND FIND OUT HOW TO HELP.
>> Tucker: WE SPENT AN ENTIRE
HOUR, ONE OF THE REASONS I'M NOT
EMBARRASSED TO SAY I ADMIRE J.D.
VANCE AS WE SPENT OVER AN HOUR
TALKING